okay
um welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and Logistics
uh first of all please mute yourself
during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions you're
welcome to mute and ask otherwise please
use chat room to post your questions so
that we can address them in Q a session
at the end
second today's gdps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no classify
this question is allowed
and finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host Jian Kao who is a Cardis
Collins professor in North Western
specializing in Innovative manufacturing
process and systems particularly in the
areas of deformation based processes and
Laser additive manifest manufacturing
processes
she is the founding director of the
University Research Center on
manufacturing science and Innovation at
Northwestern known as nimsy how served
as an associate vice president for
research at Northwestern from 2012 to
2021 she has co-authored over 250
Journal articles 20 patents and several
opinion opinion articles
Carl has been the editor-in-chief of
Journal of materials processing
processing technology since 2018 and
Professor Kyle is an elected member of
the National Academy of engineering a
fellow of American Association for
advancement of Science and many other
organizations and she's a she's the
recipient of many prestigious Awards as
well including asme had political
applied mechanics award and asme Milton
show manufacturing research method she
served as the the president of the SME
in North America manufacturing Research
Institute chair of asme manufacturing
engineering Division and the program
director at the National Science
Foundation
so today uh Professor Kao will talk
about
physics-based AI assisted design and
control in flexible manufacturing please
enjoy and expect a wonderful talk now
without further Ado let me pass the
button to uh Professor Kyle by asking
one random question as usual today's
random question is what is your idea of
the perfect day
perfect days today
yeah every day is the perfect okay yes
that's awesome okay
thank you very much
and so my goal of this talk is to share
some high level of the activities of
what we do
so in our lab we have been you know
looking at both
in numerical simulations as well as
develop Innovative manufacturing
processes so that intersection is really
interesting so what I'm the the goal is
to share as I said you know the high
level
activities and hopefully to derive some
new in detail the discussions later on
so here's the email address which is the
best way to reach me and with that let
me move forward
so the automated goal of our lab is
really looking starting from the
materials looking at the pspp in a
process structure property relationships
and the material is a base for you know
manufacturing processes right and then
what we added in are those Innovative
process and machine design the reason
that we want to design our own machine
is a capability of say imposing a new uh
Metrology system so we can have the data
that we can analyze uh knowing that the
details about how those data were
generated right as well as being able to
develop new processes it's hard to do a
process development without specific
instrumentation and the meanwhile also
to feedback to the person to do the
control and then the other part is the
design and design many times you kind of
looking at just product material and
process design separately the ultimate
goal of our lab as well as my
collaborators here in Northwestern as
well as a nationwide is trying to also
think about code design of these
different aspects and finally you know
very well is a qualification
certification that will be needed for
this so overall linking all these
together is the simulation and data so
what we have been doing also last year
with my colleague Professor when can Liu
and again is to look at the
how Ai and mechanics work together to
drive the things that I talked about
earlier for process design for process
modeling and for process control so what
I would do is in this talk I'm going to
talk about these three aspects to show
how we do that using additive metal
additive manufacturing as example as
well as some at the very end I'm going
to show some flexible she metaforming
process which is really complementary
very well with the metal additive
so with that you know
so what I want to show you this this is
our home build uh laser additive machine
and this is we cut additive rapid
prototyping instrument RP uh what it
does is a powder Brown
laser additive process directed energy
deposition and for this particular one
you know you can see the environmental
chamber left on lasers and what's up
here actually I have a more detailed
ones later on
is this one so you that this one we have
our beef on the back side we also have
four different
um you know Hoppers from Powder motion
Maps as well as two of those so we can
deposit different materials right so
this is one example that you deposit you
know for different
skills and and you can also mix it
with that the key questions that we want
to ask is what about the mechanical
properties that generated from that
deposition
certainly porosity is of the concern and
what we did by being close to our
national lab we put the DD system into
argon the high intensity high speed
x-ray Imaging of the DD so what you can
see is the deposit right here deposit
layer here in the X-ray Imaging rather
and we developed a high throughput uh
you know sample sample drone as well as
the deposition such that we can get lots
of data changing the process parameter
to see what's happening and it's just a
glance about you know the setup at Argos
so it's not curved just because of the
the the the the the pictures taken in
the in the view right but the key thing
is you know if you look at uh
the the powder is Flowing down and this
is the the male pull and many people
have been doing this for the powder bed
for the DD we were among the very first
group actually doing that so
um but the key thing you know there are
certain that we did a lot of analysis of
this for this particular group what I
want to say is uh the key thing that the
notice is also the male Pro Dynamics
right Bellport is important in terms of
how the porosity uh is generated inside
the inside the build and uh specifically
we find out for our particular
application with the DED is because you
are carrying a lot of gas actually into
the mail pool so the male put depths in
addition to typically powder bed people
looking at the width and the length so
for DED the depth is actually equally
important so because of that you know
investigation therefore from the
numerical point of view as well as from
the Practical point of view we say okay
how can we control the male product
during the buildup so the way that we do
it is if you look at our
experimental setup you can look at the
find out the width and the length right
but the depth is information is not that
visible but numerical simulation can so
we develop our own in-house
numeric simulation code called gamma and
and based on this this is a thermal
thermal thermal code basically and you
can you can see that based on the
temperature you can find out what is the
map put depth what's new here is in the
simulation
we use the melpod depth as our Target
objective function and the build up the
closed loop control and change the input
which is a laser power in the simulation
so as a result out the output of this is
using one simulation the output is a
laser power history such that you can
control the male put depth
wherever you are right so this method is
much more General in the sense in terms
of the geometry or material property
material types that you are doing and
because of this you know what we did
here's a quick glance about the fem code
gamma
and here's a governing equation which is
pretty standard and the the key part for
our particular application is we need
the speed in order to do this cross Loop
control to generate the laser power so
it's being implemented with python and
um and 2 pi is used for GPU acceleration
so that we can do this very very good
and you can see that you know uh if you
have the constant laser power moving
forward as you build up the heat got
accumulated therefore the male put depth
is also getting to be higher and higher
but with the the constant controlled
ones the laser power certainly is
changing as it's decreasing as you could
imagine and uh but the melpod depth is
very well controlled so we implement
this to our experiments RP
instrument and you can see also you know
the the heat the colorization kind of
index about you know how good is the
heat
accumulation and also you can use our
camera from the side to also indicate
that what's interesting is also uh
looking at the properties right so what
we did is particularly let's say if the
goal is whether you can have location
specific control so we build up a box
and one side of the box has a Target map
with that as a two millimeter in the
other side let's say 1.4 millimeter
different depth we know that the depth
is different thermal history will be
differential material property will be
different right so and and that's
basically using the
simulation tool I mentioned earlier to
build up the laser laser history and we
built the box and this is a and b and
once from the outside the geometry you
know they look pretty similar but so we
cut the tensor specimen from A and B and
then you pull it you know so this
restaurant curve the material behavior
for a and b are very different as you
can see right so this is interesting in
the way because sometimes many times
when you do um component design and
sometimes you want different
microstructure at different locations to
get to the properties you want for you
know creep resistance for stress you
know you have different design so this
gives you a way to say you know using
the additive manufacturer you can
actually put the different properties in
the as you need it
one thing also interesting from this one
is that particularly if you're a
material scientist you know you look at
this curve you say Okay a I have a
deeper Mel pool which means you know I
will have a slower occurring rate
and which means potentially I may have
you know a larger grain size and
therefore you know a should be lower
than b so why this a is higher than b
you know so uh we specifically actually
make sure that we got the specimen at
the right location so one thing
interesting came out is that
um the additive you know so what we did
here let's say we just build up the wall
and cut many specimens uh at this
different portion of the wall and we
also use our camera to record the time
history at different points and then
just purely using the data driven
approach to see you know what is the
significance of those time thermal
history that would influence the
properties the tensor properties right
here so we've done quite a lot of
different uh you know checking out
different uh machine learning tool and
this random photos actually comes out to
be pretty interesting so what it does is
we put every 50 degree uh in terms of
the time you spent in that 50 degree
interval and then correlate to the
strengths say tensor strength of the
material and this product shows the the
the you know relevance importance so
what's interesting from purely this data
driven ones it has two different
temperature regions has the most effect
in terms of the property and the first
one if you look at this the first one is
very much related to the measured liquid
is to solidus temperature so basically
certification rate and this is what we
were trying to control right if we're
right controlling the male per depth and
the and this is a a direct control
indication of that but the second part
is equally important in this Zoom uh is
actually very much corresponding to the
standard heat treatment temperature
so what this tells us is that the final
property that we are getting is a
combination of how you solidify it as
well as additional heating time that you
have this material point is experiencing
right so if you do that you know you can
come up with just a fitting function
right here and use those walls you know
we actually fit it and it's kind of very
interesting to see also microstructure
wise it fits this kind of uh conclusion
one thing is about the spacing which is
spacing the other one the heat treatment
is also about these additional Delta
phase generated that cut the brittle
lava phases and that helps to strengthen
the the material properties right
so from here what we are saying is okay
we can't just do Maple control we
actually need to control the thermal
history and thermal history is very
challenging things to to control right
because it's a highly dimensional
temporal and spatial design so the way
that we do it we say okay if we want to
control thermal history
the local location specific control the
in the previous approach is not going to
be enough so the way that we do it we
use a sort of differentiable simulation
and basically we rewrite our gamma code
in a
using the differentiable simulation
which is basically we use the Deep
learning library for this particular
particular application we use the Tai
Chi one but also in another one that we
are doing right now we use the Jacks
which is divided by Google
basically in those libraries that we got
uh with the with the easy Tai Chi or
Jacks it has it has a graph
representation about this partial
differentiable simulation right the
partial differential equation and use a
graph what it can do is it can give you
the gradient information for free where
you are doing the forward analysis so
it's automatic differentiation provided
by those libraries and help us to
compute basically this Jacobian that you
know traditionally you have to do it by
yourself
so
so it's a greeting based continuous
optimization and people have been used
using differentiable simulation for
robotics path planning as well as you
know this is becoming really popular
these days to also look at the fluids
you know heat transfer as we we have it
right here so for us you know this is
what I mentioned and earlier right we
use these tools to to develop the
another tool that for our manufacturing
process design
so what it does it can combine the
physics-based assimilation and then what
we do is
we represent the laser power using a
neural network and here you can think
about these are all partial differential
equations and which you can put
everything together under a global
optimization framework
and with that what we can say is if I
want to have specific thermal history I
can use the you know run this overall
simulations and get that what you want
so the key idea is we represent the
laser power as a Time series and go
through the fem simulation which is
differentiable get the thermal history
and then we do the uh the optimization
so for example with this thin wall and
multiple points if the blue is what we
want
and we feed into the the atom
optimization to uh to uh
basically framework and then create the
laser power as this red line versus if
it's constant it's a green you know so
as you can see the green the thermal
response from different points are very
different
so we got this laser power history and
then we implement it into RP
so you can see ABCD you know depends on
where you are you you have different
thermal history and remember we want
that thermal history so we basically
shift it so this product is because each
point you have a different birth time so
we shift it and compare for example the
thermal history that we want uh the dash
lines are the constant laser power and
this solid lines are the one using our
um you know computed laser power
so this is promising and then the other
thing that I mentioned it was
interesting is remember I talk about the
second time period which is important
temperature
um reaching is important so for this one
basically after each simulation you can
accumulate calculate the accumulated
time and go through the same exercise
and this is a you know computed from the
average point of view and this is our
experiments
um to also you know looking at the uh
the time spent there so uh the bottom
line is it is showing the
advantages but I think there are still
more work that needs to be can be done
to further optimize the optimization
tool as well as the computational
um the the the powers so with that you
know I talk about the process design and
then the next point is about the process
modeling as I mentioned earlier process
modeling needs to be fast enough to fit
into this process design and one thing
with the additive manufacturing certain
is a microstructure prediction
so if you look at the powder bed looking
at the microstructure and typically the
the best you know the absolute the the
best one is people use the face field
method to predict the microstructure and
phase field in simulation is pretty
expensive uh so the question is
typically people are looking at just
around the micro slides might feel
Micron but I feel my crop and it could
already cost quite a lot so the question
is how do we speed up this you know
because we we build a a very large part
and the male process is a you know 200
Micron and sometimes could be even
bigger right
so the way that we do this this is one
example looking at the physics embed
graph Network so it is inspired by the
graph Network
um but it's not using data training okay
so what you can see here is this is the
seed grams and what we do is for each
Grant's original Grand it treated as a
node so for the node we have the
information such as temperature grain
orientation and gram volume
and then for the edge is where the
physics happening right so for the edge
is actually we are solving the L and K
equations uh to to to look at you know
how that will actually calculate uh the
liquid solid fractures also control the
grain growth so that's physics pay a
fixed physics is calculated around the
edge but the what it does is it build up
the graph Network
um and uh to to do this calculation so
it's kind of reduce order modeling
approach and then you calculate the free
energy and then minimize that so by
doing this you know this is a comparison
between the PGM model
versus the DNS and as I mentioned this
is kind of the reviews order model so
you have less degree of freedom and the
good thing is uh you know it's a speed
up quite a lot
and because of this now first you know
let's check how it calculate how it
works right
um so you compare for example the direct
numerical simulation versus the red one
is a PGN and this one you compare you
know the grand volumes they're pretty
close as well as the aspect ratio coming
out from these two different
methods and this is a you know
reasonably well
and because we can do this now you can
actually model a larger volume right
because the computation is very
efficient so now you can calculate a
larger volume and then you can monitor
kind of simulate multi-layers so what
you do is you you use the previous
calculation as a result as a seed for
the next layer
and with that we can now simulate for
example this is two millimeter by two
millimeter one millimeter simulations
and really you know interesting you can
see this Grand growth which is actually
what also people find out in their
simulation
um so the idea is if you have these
grants then you can use also Crystal
plasticity to calculate the mechanical
properties right
um and so in the crystal plasticity
piece you know I don't have time to talk
about here but you can also think about
once you have the crystal plasticity
that's still pretty expensive calculated
um and then you capture how do you
capture the plasticity Behavior also
more efficiently so the way that we do
it is this was uh back to 2019
and we use the numerical simulation to
to generate lots of data so here you
know because we know the material
behavior is also extreme pass and low
pass dependency right so using the
design of the element approach you can
you can generate for this particular one
we use 10 000 different samples
generated and then using
uh the the Deep Learning Network uh
basically for that time you know we have
the fully connected convolution neural
network as well as STM and what's new
here the architecture-wise we also
incorporate the initial uh
microstructure into this representation
into this deep neural network such that
it has a good you know initial physics
and because of this you know you can see
the difference between final element
calculated which has a discrete point
about the yield Locus as well as purely
neural network based calculated as a
solid ones
um and they they match pretty well and
particularly it could actually also
capture the evolution of the network
which numerically if you do that it
could be very expensive
so overall you know right now we are
actually trying to develop the whole
package uh this is the code is at GitHub
so if you scan it you can you can find
it
um so the idea is you know for Jax am
you can use this one to simulate uh
using the Jets you know Library as I
mentioned earlier to sit with the
thermal fluids and with the heat input
with the heat input you can also you
know simulate the local grain growth and
with the grand girls using simulate to
the crystal plasticity and then also we
have fem version which you can do the
topology optimization so that I the
ultimately once it's fully built up you
can have location specific material
properties coming from the additive and
do the the whole so you know co-design
as I mentioned earlier so this is a
long-term goal and we're coming you know
closer and closer which I think is very
promising
um
finally I want to talk about process
control and so for a process control one
key part is also sensing and in my lab
we have about 40 percent numerical uh
numerical computational people and maybe
60 percent are experiment experimental
lists and some of the students actually
because they're covering both areas but
the point is you know for experimental
implementation we also need good sensing
data so what we do for this one is we
use a photodive system
and which was originally provided by
Sigma Labs but what we did is uh we we
have these photodiac system lamp with
our laser laser path and this is I
believe the first implementation for the
DD system and you just two different
wavelengths you know calculate the the
relevant temperature
and and then it's interesting that you
can see this is the measurement
and uh if you take the second derivative
of this temperature measurement uh you
can actually corresponding to find the
liquid is and solid this temperature so
this is where we find out the dash line
the liquid service temperature for this
internet 718 if you look at the
literature there's a large range of the
error of values people reported and
that's not a surprise because a little
in a composition change but changing our
liquid is instead of this temperature
but the key point is now we can actually
Institute measure that
and then when we measure the cooling
rate if you have lower cooling rate this
you know matches with the existing
Hardware measurement which is great and
also for high current rate this one we
have a sampling rate could be up to 200
kilohertz so for this one we can
actually measure High cooling rate that
the others was saturated and won't be
able to measure
so um
you know I talk a lot about the DD but
we also have the high resolution same
system Implement for the powder bed and
the idea is can we use this as a tool
such that we can do Institute closed
loop control
so in order to do the closed loop
control first thing that we need to
figure it out is make sure the data is
not too noisy because otherwise you are
going to get something undesired if you
look at the real-time measurement this
is a different layer assembly about
actually this is following the laser
path you know so the resolution cleanse
could be about 10 Micron by 10 micron
um so the idea is if you just put
everything together there's a lot of
data in a 50 gigabyte data just for this
build
um so what we did is we used machine
learning based to predict the malput
temperature of the next layer based on
the previous layer so the the key
message I want to uh this is also using
the random Forest method the key message
I want to come across here is that that
this definition of the features also
involve the physics understanding about
what's important so when we put these
things together it gives us a good
prediction as you can see here you know
the prediction is almost you can think
about it as a filter
and with that you know the noise are
gone
but also it still capture some of the
fundamental physics right here for
example
um this one as a laser turn around you
can see that you know first part is
lower and then you can actually because
it's a right turn around the temperature
increase
um how much time do I have
well you have a 10 to 15 minutes okay
okay that's good
um
so uh for for for process control one
thing is really important is actually uh
we have lots of different data's coming
together so data Fusion or data uh
alignment is is important for us so for
this one we have the Machine level
control uh as well as the CT scan post
CT scan as well as the Institute data so
we put all these together you can then
you can see uh where the porosity are
and that will help to guide the process
design
so um it was also interesting recently
we had this uh sensor array Sigma lab
system as I mentioned earlier uh put
together with the
um with the you know we went to the
argonal National Lab and in situated you
look from the top of the sigma lab
system as well as the X-ray which is a
projection 2D progression about what's
happening
so you can see that this is kind of we
treated the X-ray at the ground tooth
and you can see this one laser is moving
around and here is the male pool and as
you go around you can also see sometimes
it leaves you know porosity right so the
key thing what we are looking for is we
use this as a ground choose but the
question is can we use the x-rays you
know the the top view
and using this this set of the
experiments to train
um our model such that you can just use
the sensor array to detect what's
happening uh in in the underneath this
right which you cannot see that from the
top but you can only see it with the
X-ray
so with this goal uh we this these are
some details I just skip
um so we
took lots of data
and so the first part is The annotation
of the male pool and then which takes a
long time you know one minute per image
and we have 250 000 images
so this is a perfect uh occasion to use
um you know deep learning to help us
annotate the the mail pool so that's the
first step and then some of the other
things you know which is now realistic
coming from the prediction we have to
remove that based on understanding about
the the physics after it's done and then
we try to correlate the
as well as the top signal right coming
uh coming up so I should change this
this is already accepted
um
so
the point is uh yeah it's just recently
accepted you know just a day ago so
um the point I want to say this is
actually from the top uh x-ray photodive
system you can see those Peaks and
what's interesting with those Peaks is
also corresponding to the mail put
depths collection
um so you know many times when we think
about this you know whether this is a
noise or it's really happening uh it
actually it's actually have some kind of
physics uh involved right there but the
other thing which is interesting is you
know you see additional Peaks right here
which doesn't corresponding to the male
put depth collapse and what's happening
right here is actually there are some
geometric dependency so
um the conclusion that we got from this
set of the experiment is that uh it
cannot be just to the signal it's
actually you need to consider what
geometry you're building so the geometry
Factor has to take into account whether
it's overhand uh or just you know solid
base
so that's that's interesting
um and the other one you know there's a
little Peak right here
um but you don't see anything here the
geometry here is actually very similar
to here what happened is the sampling
rate of this one is 200 kilohertz and
this one is just 50 kilohertz so I think
what we did is we pick up something that
is kind of missed by the other uh other
tool uh so
you know lots of data and and actually
look forward for the collaborations to
analyze those data together so I want to
just kind of uh finish it up by saying
um you know physics based and the data
driven ones has lots of future for us to
look at this qualification right so when
we look at the upside you know of the
sensing data from the top we can pick up
those things that you won't even see uh
with the with the with the detailed
x-ray because of the sampling rate so
maybe we can use those data for combined
with the simulation we can do a
qualification as we build
so the other part which I'm going to
finish up really quickly the other
process that we do in our lab for the
flexible manufacturing process is called
double-sided incremental for me so for
this one you know we actually build our
own machine as well and instead of using
tooling we use two you know as I
mentioned the two tools uh geometric
independent tools to move around
CNC controlled and you can make very
different parts the challenge for uh the
thing here is because the deformation is
all local so to numerical simulate this
uh maybe if I take 30 minutes to build
it numerical simulation to to simulate
really well it could be easily two weeks
so similar challenge in terms of how can
we speed it up and uh in application of
this process is actually in a much
faster and cheaper to do it you know
with the various low volume production
so company has already been picking it
this up this is Nissan picking it up and
here in the States you know there's a
Makino Labs also picking up you know you
can see all these different parts built
within a week
and for legacy part which is
particularly challenging if you have a
legacy products no tooling no drawing
available uh and using this one you can
actually speed up with a week but
traditionally you can actually take a
year or more to get this part
um so lots of control also going on you
can do the offline control to do the
inline control uh to get the geometry
right so overall you know recently we
are also part of the ERC engineering
Research Center we call Hammer which is
a hybrid autonomous manufacturing moving
from Evolution to Revolution so the idea
is you can think about all these
flexible manufacturing
um tools as toolbox and you can build
the parts depends on what kind of
microstructure what kind of material
properties you need
so the key thing behind this is what I
presented early looking at you know some
of those future directions like
mechanics mechanistic AI to determine
physics needed and uncertain
quantification is important I haven't
talked too much about this but we have
collaborated working on this reinforced
learning is interesting because then we
can also as well as transfer learning to
get to different materials
we can use this for process Innovation
for simulation tools as well as
sometimes you know the human machine
interactions for example the incremental
forming you know sometimes English well
and the other process you have human
involved as well but the other thing I
think a very very critical is also
bridges of designers and manufacturers
we need the database we need the
automatic manufacturing process Plan
Generation we also I call it functional
Metrology basically qualification as you
build
um so lots of interesting you know areas
to go for and I would like to
acknowledge our group uh for sure
without them we can't do it as well as
our sponsors with the federal as well as
private
so thank you very much
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk
um it was very nice
a lot a lot of things are going on here
I can see that yeah it was yeah you're a
really actively working on wonderful
stuff okay let's have a Q any session
and anyone has a questions
um you can admit yourself and ask
questions and I asked a question for
your uh case one uh oh first of all
thanks for the great talk yeah the case
in your case one you have the neural
network connected to a differentiable
stimulation and when then you calculate
the the loss
and then updates do you also update like
both updates in the neural network and
the simulation or you just okay how how
did you update the simulation
so the simulation the simulation is a
physics based assimilation right so the
the neural network is really
representing the the process parameter
so we actually run the physics-based
assimilation at each iteration the
difference is the physics-based
assimilation and in the even in the
forward analysis your gradient
calculation is done automatically by you
know jacks or taiji so so when you do
the atom on top of that we have Adam we
use atom and basically you use that just
to update the process parameter
does that make sense to you I see and
and also like are there any cases like
the the model will like the interactions
between the updates of the weights in
the neural network and also like the
simulation framework are there like some
trade-off or like some interactions
between these two
yes so if you notice you
see time when we
um Yes actually let me go to the slide I
don't know which one let me just uh
if you there
too many slides oh sorry
okay I'll close enough I think
right so one thing you notice for
example
um in case one
the laser power you see that there's
actually have lots of ups and downs
right the change of the frequency is
much more than the case two for example
this is very very uh gentle change and
part of this is because it's trade-off
as you mentioned
okay thank you
related
um question in order to you know utilize
both
you know simulation code and the neural
net at the same time the simulation
quotes it must be pretty fast
and but if it
needs to be fast and you have to trade
off the the Fidelity like the accuracy
of the simulation yes yes
how do you account for that I guess
right higher tolerance um it's okay to
have the high error yeah so this is as I
mentioned this is something that
um even back there
hold on let me I think I have a slide to
show
uh this
yeah this one now this this was our kind
of uh
you know we use a simulation and
basically you can see the simulation
experiments right you know so uh it
requires calibration for some of those
parameters to kind of give us something
confidence that we can use it
you know and uh suddenly we are now
modeling for example uh the detailed
about the uh like macaronium
flow in the uh in the simulation in the
experiments so we are losing some of
those physics for sure and that's why in
the current development
I think I have sorry try to get to that
yeah so for example in the current
simulation right uh
so in for the differentiable simulation
I showed earlier was just for using this
path level but the path level let's say
the temperature input is very much like
just a gaussian temperature to represent
the beam and laser b but little detail
that like what you see the particle
interactions you know with Maple we
didn't capture that so the goal that we
want to develop at this level is to use
this as an input to that one
you know and so so the part level could
be still
computational efficiency for the design
but nevertheless it's going to be more
accurate with more physics involved
okay so it's more future work is
required yeah yeah definitely
okay uh Kevin you wanna admit hi um
thank you for the talk it was very
impressive to me I also have a question
about that um optimization
about that differential with simulation
combined with the neural network and
though what are what are the example of
those obtrainable variables of the
neural network I I guess I can see
when you try to back prop okay in front
of a
physics space simulation you get the
optimal laser power right and uh I guess
there is some other like
is this sort of related to how to
control that laser power or yeah so
hopefully
um we can control the laser power uh
depends on you know your experimental
setup we can also control for example in
our experiment we can also control the
base plate temperature
so that's another one you can put in
there I think also you know in one of
our undergraduate projects we also
developed the cooling nozzle from the
side
so if we incorporate that we can also
have the side cooling nozzle locally as
another control variable so I think
what variable to control it's not that
much limit in terms of the numerical uh
tour rather than
experimental side you know where you can
control how fast you can control
I say so I guess
this neural network kind of like
replacing those physics part like
instead of like
implementing all those physics parties
into physics-based simulation I guess is
some part is replaced by the neural
network right correct okay right right
yeah so the reason we did
you know you don't have to do this you
know I think you can also just using
um the re you can also use maybe just
some kind of simple uh function to
represent that the reason that we do
that is really just because it's pretty
much in the same framework uh with the
differentiable simulation so you can use
that you know
integration wise very seamlessly right
so this is basically your trainable
variables and then you can it's kind of
interpret interpolator from here to here
and uh and you can easily
expand that and depends on what kind of
you know physical parameters you can
control
I said thank you so much it was a very
great talk okay thank you
is there any other question you cannot
mute yourself and ask
well um I I was really impressed I mean
you're able to do the multi-layer and
then you know analyze the the previous
temperature layer and then you know use
that for the next layer and usually we
try to do that as well but because of
the um you know the computational costs
of the High Fidelity model we have here
is a lot slower than the model you have
it's it's kind of bottleneck there oh
yeah so for this particular one this
these are the measurements not the
computational
um so but you you train the neural net
that's right yeah yeah we trained it
becomes really fast so
um
the the the key thing we actually have a
recent paper just accepted on this uh is
what we learned is that to give you
better prediction you also need to have
the previous almost the previous 20 30
layers
data altogether to use to predict the
next one because for this one it's easy
in the sense that there is only a very
simple geometry so the recent paper we
actually look at all these different
geometries and you can see that the the
neighborhood as well as the previous
buildup are very important so we
actually we show that we need the the
previous 20 layers or sometimes even
sometimes even 50 layers in order to
give us a good prediction for the next
layer I see and I think the
computational time is doable in the way
to think about the recording you know
the recording will take time so it's
it's very much doable for that time
frame so it's not going to be
really useful if you want to do a
following laser point wise
so still layer layer level control not
laser point and Laser pass control
yeah yeah
sounds good
um I think you can learn a lot from you
um on the Philadelphia Printing and the
process optimization side
is there any other question from
audience
well it's now let's let's yeah yeah so
feel free to send me email you know and
love to you know have some further
conversations yeah yeah you know
hopefully we're gonna have the more
collaboration with you after this
seminar thank you thank you thank you
very much bye